[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN PULSIFER: Hello.
Welcome.
My name is Jonathan Pulsifer.
I'm a security
engineer at Shopify.
And today, I'm
here with a couple
other folks whom I'll
introduce momentarily.
But we're going to talk to
you about keyless entry, that
is securely accessing Google
Cloud Platform services
from within Kubernetes.
Before we get
started though, I'd
like to just mention
that we have a Dory here.
I have not used this before.
Good luck.
If you would like to
ask us some questions,
this is how we can do this.
But also, we're going
to have a pedestal mic
to take any questions from
the audience when we're done.
So again, hi.
My name is John.
I'm a Staff Infrastructure
Security Engineer at Shopify.
I like to hang around
with Mike and other folks
on the Kubernetes Product
Security Committee,
and I'm a Google Developer
Expert for the Cloud Platform
with a focus on security.
Before coming to Shopify,
I got my tin foil hat
in the Royal Canadian Navy where
I'm a self-described SIGINT
Cyber Sailor, so that's
where that came from.
And previous to that,
I did a little bit
of instructing for the SANS
Institute in cyber security.
You can find me on the
internet @jonpulsifer.
With me here today we have
Aaron Small who's a PM,
that is Product Manager
for Google, GKE,
and Kubernetes Security.
He works on identity
things, and has recently
pushed out the third-party
audit for security
for Kubernetes, which
is really, really neat,
so look him up and look that up.
I think it's fantastic.
Previously, I used to be
a PM for other places,
and I wish I could bake
as well as Aaron can.
My bread doesn't turn out
as nice as his these days.
Aaron cares a lot
about the blast radius
of things and trust, generally.
Mike Danese, who you may know
from the Kubernetes community,
is a Software Engineer at Google
and works on GKE Security.
He's the chair of the
Kubernetes special interest
group for auth, that's
SIG Auth, and is
the Tech Lead on GKE identity
stuff and likes Seattle a lot.
So before we dive
into the meat, I
have a little bit of
a story to tell you.
And before we get
into the story,
I'd like to thank the
folks at BrightCarbon
for turning our diagram into
what it was before into what it
is now, and that's very pretty.
And we use this to
talk about Shopify.
So Shopify, for
those who don't know,
is a multi-channel
commerce platform
that, on Google
Cloud Platform now,
has over 50 GKE
clusters in production
that power over
800,000 businesses
in 175 different countries.
And we allow people to
sell things to people.
The people who sell things
are everyone from me,
my grandmother, and then big
brands such as Kylie Cosmetics,
Allbirds, and a lot more.
So meet Emily.
Emily is a dev degree
intern at Shopify.
The dev degree program is like
a work-integrated learning
program that takes first-year
university students
and puts them on the fast
track to being developers
that are really impactful.
And we do this by layering on
personal development skills
and technology stacks like
the ones we use at Shopify--
primarily Ruby on Rails--
feedback loops, and other
things to really help them
grow and become developers.
It's like a really intense
co-op program, right?
And she's doing all this
stuff on top of a degree.
For someone who
doesn't have a degree,
I think this is really
next-level stuff,
and I just don't
quite understand it.
I don't think that I could
work as hard as she does.
But in any event, Emily
is studying her first year
of computer science at
Carleton University in Ottawa,
and we help her
build cool things.
So in just a few
clicks, Emily is
empowered to create new
things, explore her ideas.
She doesn't have to reason about
debugging our production stack.
It just works, right?
And with a little familiarity,
maybe like a breeze
through the documentation--
I mean, who reads those--
Emily and other
developers like her,
Shopify can really
deploy like a fresh Ruby
on Rails application that
is completely configured,
everything from Cloud SQL,
Redis, Memcached protected
by our implementation of
an identity or a a proxy,
that's Minerva, and
the cloud bosses,
and the other friendly
Kubernetes controllers that
keep our cloud fluffy.
The pieces of the cloud that
I want to highlight today
are the ones that
reason about identity.
And one that we haven't
really talked about before,
the pieces that bootstrap
our cloud run times
is Ground Control.
And Ground Control was missing
from our previous diagrams
because it was just
like one of those things
that you thought would go away.
We built it and it was
pretty resourceful.
It was quite scrappy.
But then it turned out to
be like a critical part
of the production stack.
And so I figured I'd
talk about Ground Control
as it relates to the larger
identity problem at Shopify.
So the parts of Ground Control
that are really important
are the initialization of
the Kubernetes namespace,
the generation of the asymmetric
keypair for encrypted JSON.
That's where developers
store our secrets.
You can find that at
GitHub, Shopify, ejson.
And the last piece, the
part that relates to today,
is the creation of the Google
Cloud Platform service account
identity.
So this is like, the
genesis of identity
for a service at Shopify really
happens at Ground Control.
So some other
controllers that help
keep the cloud fluffy
at Shopify, these
are the Cloudbuddies.
We really like to talk
about the Cloudbuddies,
because it takes away all
of this technical complexity
and makes it more friendly, and
so these are my favorite ones.
Thanks to David Neal for
bringing the Cloudbuddies
to life.
NetPolbuddy ensures that our
Kubernetes network policy
objects are in place.
RBACbuddy does the same
thing for Kubernetes RBAC.
Bucketbuddy really helps us
lifecycle our GCS buckets.
And Accountabilibuddy,
my favorite,
grants IAM bindings
for GCP APIs and binds
the service accounts to be
able to access these things.
Google Service Accounts
are something else, right?
To use an east coast expression,
they're right out of her.
I'm from the east
coast of Canada.
I don't really like to use
$12-words to express myself,
so you'll find I use a
lot of colorful, concise,
and expressive
language to do that.
And so, the few
things that I wanted
to highlight about
Google Service Accounts,
and that is to
demystify them, is
that, one, there are two types.
You have the Google
managed service accounts
and you have user-managed
service accounts.
The Google managed service
accounts are the ones
that you'll find
in your IAM page
that look like your project
number, which a lot of people
don't know, at a
Google product project
dot IAM dot g service
account dot com.
You can't generate
credentials off these.
These are the robots that
keep Google's cloud fluffy
and empower the
ship, as it were.
The user-managed service
accounts, the user-managed GSAs
are the part that's hard.
And I want to talk
about why they're hard
and, hopefully, you will come
out understanding that they are
difficult to manage as well.
So the second part of that
is that the keys are not
well understood.
We have this documentation
in the Cloud Platform
that says like, hey,
look, security bits.
Let's just create this
JSON blob and jam it
in this Google application
credentials environment
variable.
Quick hands up.
Who can explain to me--
sorry, audience
participation is definitely
going to happen today via me
and Aaron and the whole works.
So hands up if you
can explain to me
all the technical
bits that power
Google application credentials.
So we've got like
the security PMs.
We have one, and that's it.
That says all that it
needs to say, does it not?
It's just a fun security bit
that you throw over the wall
to the security team and
say, have fun, right?
The last piece that
I wanted to highlight
is that it works, thanks.
Shopifam has left
infrasec, right?
And we provide a lot of
support to our developers.
We have over 1,000
developers at Shopify,
and they don't know how
service accounts work either.
And so we have to
help them figure out
this maze of credentials and
identity and access management,
and what it all means.
Thirdly, the keys are
unreasonably hard to manage.
And I say that because,
buried in the documentation
says, in other language,
that you should really,
really, really not use
user-managed service
accounts unless you have
the following in place.
And again, hands up if everyone
knows how to fully manage
a PKI, like very well.
We have a few again.
But like, we've all
created a CA, right?
We've all created
the self-signed CA.
But what about like managing
CRLs at scale or OCSP?
How does that all work and
where does this all fit in?
These are core
competencies of a PKI
that's actually required if
you are to effectively manage
thousands of these keys.
And so that's the
really hard bit.
It's not easy, and
that's what I want
you to come away with today.
So user-managed GSA
credentials live forever.
10 years is forever in
cloud years, by the way.
And they're actually
technologies that we're
familiar with already.
They're typically,
in the JSON blobs,
a 2K RSA key pair generated off
the PKI that is your project,
and the common name
is it's unique ID.
So if you think you can
just like delete things
and use those certs
again to come back,
it just doesn't work.
There's a lot of nuance in
that, a lot of PKI nuance,
and it's not easy.
Shopify found out that
we push the limits
of a lot of the products
in Google Cloud Platform
because we poke at the bits
that people don't expect us to,
the PMs don't
really expect us to.
And we found out the
hard way that, when
you reach 1,000 user-managed
GSAs per project,
that IAM doesn't let
you list them anymore.
And so, given that, it's
like a slight denial
of service against IAM.
We got the feedback
that we should probably
do something else,
and so now we have
multiple projects which only
hold GSA service account
credentials.
Like, that's wild, right?
And how do you reason
about these things?
Are we confident that these
credentials aren't misused?
An employee that
had a hot exit, are
we confident that any keys
didn't go along with them?
We generally do a good job
at auditing these things,
but there are just
a lot of keys that
have grown with us
through the years
that I would deem as
sensitive, and we'd
like to do something better.
We'd like to change.
And so, given all of this,
this doesn't include identities
for like the instances or the
nodes or the GKE node pools.
This is just like
service accounts
that have been created
for applications
that run on our cloud platform.
This is not the rest of them.
These 1,200 so service
accounts that I mentioned
are just for services.
So we, in fact, have a lot more.
So all that to say
is that containers
that run at Shopify
in our cloud platform
are experiencing what I would
call a conflict of identity.
And you know, we've
created these Cloudbuddies
and our other
communities controllers
and some other automation.
We're a software company.
We create cool things to help
solve our problems for us,
but scaling does come
with its challenges
like the over 1,000 service
accounts per project thing.
So the product that
you're about to see,
the technology that
you're about to see really
hopes to address a
lot of these problems
and further consolidate the
identities of workloads,
bridging trust
domains, as it were.
In Kubernetes, we would
just call this a namespace.
If we could just namespace
a series of identities,
wouldn't that be neat?
But who am I to say?
So with that, I
like definitions.
I like these $12-dollar
words and expressions.
Aaron will give you
a lot more of these,
or a few more definitions.
I stole one from him,
and it's this one
because I think it's
really important.
So we do a lot of talking
about workloads today.
Workloads are
everything everywhere.
And what I mean by that
is that they are software
running on a computer, they are
containers, they're binaries.
They're just a thing talking to
a modern authentication system,
right?
And so workloads at Shopify,
including human workloads,
leverage short-lived
signed JWTs,
"jots" as it were, for
tools G Cloud, kubectl.
All these tools use
these technologies.
And so the impact here
really is that we interact
with these
technologies as humans
more than we probably
realize that we do.
It powers
accounts.shopify.com-- you know,
that is our identity
application at Shopify--
every oauth2proxy
that you've ever used,
the bitly oauth2proxy,
BuzzFeed SSO, the whole thing,
and Google.
So it's largely my
opinion that we should be
consolidating these identities.
We should be consolidating
all these technologies
and using them just
as everybody else is.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Aaron,
and he's going to show
you something new.
AARON SMALL: Thank you.
Let's see if I can
figure this out.
So as I was getting
ready for this talk
and putting these
slides together,
a lot of the feedback
I got from my peers
was that I tried to cover
too many complicated topics
in the time that I had and that
I didn't go into enough depth
on any given one of them to
actually explain it in full.
And they were right, but
I think that actually
points to a bigger story.
And that bigger story is
that identity and credential
management is hard,
like capital H hard.
It's a really deep space.
You have to worry about
credential issuance
and distribution and that long
list that Jonathan listed off
earlier, and revocation
and auditing and renewal
and exfiltration protection--
that's my first $12-dollar
word--
and replay protection,
and on and on and on.
If you add to that the alphabet
soup of all the standards you
have to deal with, like
OIDC, JWTs, RFC 7518,
and then you layer
on top of that all
the unique authentication
and authorization systems
that each cloud provider
implements, I can end up
talking for like two hours
when all Emily asked was,
how do I access cloud
storage from GKE?
So I did the work to
simplify the presentation.
We won't cover my favorite RFCs
and their finer implementation
details, but more
importantly than that,
I think we simplified
the practice.
Jonathan from eastern Canada
addressed these problems
with some really
heroic engineering
and actually shouldered
some of Emily's burden,
and he definitely made
Emily's life easier.
I want to take a step back
and look at how this works
for the rest of
the world though,
except I'm from a big old
west-coast city by the bay,
and I'm going to use as many
$12-dollar words as I can.
So the first thing you
do is you go to IAM
and you create an
IAM service account.
Then you download its key.
And when you download
that key, you
get this lovely little warning
and it's perfectly accurate.
Like, don't get me wrong.
You should read it carefully,
because it's perfectly true.
And then you have
all these keys.
And this is actually
a screenshot from one
of my own personal accounts.
And I have a very good
reason, I assure you,
for having this many
keys downloaded,
but I'm not going to
tell you what it is.
Once you have this key, you
run some kubectl commands
against it and you end up
with a Kubernetes secret.
And then you can update
your Kubernetes YAML files
with this secret, and
you have to mount it
in places that the Google
Client Libraries know to look.
And that's pretty much it.
Once you mount this secret
in all the right places,
your Kubernetes
workloads know which
identity to use when
talking to Google Cloud.
And at first glance,
there's nothing
really wrong with
this approach, right?
Like, from a strict threat
modeling perspective,
as long as there is no
vulnerabilities anywhere
in your application or
anywhere in Kubernetes
or in any of your dependencies,
it's probably fine.
Kubernetes handles secrets
in really rational ways.
It's not going to
accidentally expose it
to the wrong workload.
However, manageability
gets quite complex.
If you have thousands
of these keys
that you're managing
as individual secrets
in various Kubernetes
clusters, you
would have to build a
system to manage them.
And then, furthermore, if
it does get compromised,
if someone does manage
to get their hands on one
of these secrets, they
can exfiltrate it.
They can take it with them.
And once they have
it back home, they
can use it to perform
whatever malicious action they
had planned until
either you notice
or until it expires in
10 years, which I guess
is forever in cloud land.
So this all comes down to
this concept of blast radius,
and security professionals
like me always
talk about blast radius.
But what this really
means is, let's first
assume that something's
going to go wrong.
When this thing goes
wrong, what else breaks?
And I don't mean what
pieces of your application
stop working, I mean,
what fundamental security
assumptions are no longer valid
when something else goes wrong?
We used to call this
defense in depth.
Now we called it building
to reduce blast radius.
It all means roughly
the same thing,
which is making it as hard
as possible for an attacker
to turn one vulnerability in
one part of your application
into a successful
attack on another.
Brief aside on containers.
I love containers.
They help a lot when it comes
to reducing the blast radius.
You can use some really
cool security features.
You can lock them down to
only access certain kernel--
what's the word?
That's right.
You can lock them down to
only access certain sys calls.
You can make their
file systems read only.
The Kubernetes
networking plugins
can provide good
policies to limit access.
Then there's products built
on top of the whole thing,
like Istio, that can provide
great encryption of all
these inter-container
communication,
and can provide a
management layer.
But in real life,
these containers
have to interact
with each other,
and they also have to interact
with other cloud services.
And once you do that,
you find yourself back
at square one, which was
credential management is hard.
When I'm building a
cloud-native application,
I care about the credentials
and I care about blast radius,
but that doesn't mean I want
to manage the individual life
cycles of every
secret and every key
that my identity
system relies on.
I do want to make
these broad security
statements like, this component
can only talk to that thing,
this cloud service only
has access to this role
or can call this one API.
The implementation details of
credential lifecycle management
and key lifecycle management
should be automatic,
and it should be managed
by the cloud provider.
I guess what I'm
saying is the best
way to solve the credential
management problem is
to get somebody else to do it
for you, especially if they'll
be fool enough to stand up on
stage and volunteer to do it.
There's so many edge
cases to consider.
There's so many best practices
to be aware of and to enforce,
I would want a whole team of
people that were dedicated
to its design and maintenance.
OK, my turn for
audience participation,
although I can barely see you.
So who has used a Kubernetes
service account or an IAM
service account on
any cloud provider?
All right, I want you
to keep your hands up
if you've ever built your own
identity system from scratch.
OK, so there's a couple of you.
That's awesome.
Towards the end of the talk,
I'm going to come back up
and we can nerd out
on implementation.
Until then, stand by.
So Shopify was
really, really great
to work with on
this problem space.
They have, like
Jonathan mentioned,
this habit of pushing on all
the bits of our service we maybe
didn't expect to get
pushed on that hard.
When we talked about
this set of problems,
their perspective was really
valuable to the eventual design
we landed on.
We heard from Jonathan
and many others
that the process of accessing
Google Cloud Services
from within Kubernetes
Engine was really onerous,
that managing these
long-lived secrets and all
these IAM service
accounts was very painful.
And then additionally, as
security professionals,
neither myself nor Jonathan were
happy with all these keys just
flying around everywhere,
either being unmanaged entirely
or being managed in
a decentralized way.
So we decided to take a
crack at the solution,
and this is what
we came up with.
Today, I'm introducing
Workload Identity.
It'll be in beta in
a few weeks, and it's
designed to help people
like Jonathan and Emily,
and also, for all the
security folks in the room,
to help you sleep a
little better at night.
Last year, I gave a
big speech about trust
and how using a cloud provider
is an exercise in trust.
I think part of
that relationship
is we need to offer
services for you
to build on top of that are
built on really strong security
principles.
So Workload Identity makes it
easy to access Google Cloud
products from within
Kubernetes Engine
without becoming an
expert in identity,
without becoming an expert
in credential management.
You don't have to manage
any keys or any secrets.
Related to this, we have this
new concept called an identity
namespace, and I'll go
into exactly what that
means more in a minute.
But in short, it's
going to allow
you to define the relationship
between Kubernetes
workloads and the
Google Cloud identities
that they should
use without a bunch
of excess micromanagement.
It's going to work
across clusters,
and it works with the existing
Google Client Libraries
that you're probably
already using.
I think if you're going to
get someone else to solve
a problem like this
for you, it's only fair
that you understand
the kinds of principles
that led to the design
they ended up with.
I like sharing
principles like this.
I think it builds
a lot of trust,
and I think it
helps you understand
why we made the
trade offs we did,
and maybe even give you a little
insight into the direction
that we're going.
So the first major principle
we designed towards
was least-privilege.
All that really means is
not giving any one component
more permissions than
it actually needs.
In this instance,
it means we can't
force you to be less stingy
with your permissions
than you want to be.
And specifically, that means we
couldn't rely on the underlying
virtual machine service account
identity because of the way
Kubernetes scheduling works.
Your workload could end up
scheduled on any given node,
and in that case, you'd have
to grant too many permissions
to the underlying node.
Secondly, if a component that's
running Workload Identity
gets compromised, we
need its blast radius
to be as small as possible.
We primarily achieve
this by making sure
the long-lived durable secrets
that underpin this whole system
are never exposed
to workloads at all,
and the access tokens that we
do expose expire very quickly.
And finally, I
wanted the solution
to play nice with Kubernetes.
Kubernetes Engine customers
are probably our customers
because they love Kubernetes.
So we wanted to
design the solution
in a way that fit in seamlessly
and followed the best
practices and the way that
Kubernetes likes to do things.
All right.
So if we're going to integrate
seamlessly with Kubernetes,
and if we're going to
build this identity system,
let's take a brief
aside and look
at what we have to work with.
This is like a
Kubernetes cluster.
You've probably seen it before.
It's got a control plane.
It's got nodes.
Nodes have pods.
Your workload lives
in those pods.
Got a bunch of API objects.
I didn't think we'd
have a screen this big,
so you probably can read them.
On the left, we've
got a bunch that
result in the creation of pods.
And then on the
right, you've got
a bunch that provide various
controls for your cluster.
The one that we actually
care about, in this case,
is the service account.
So the Kubernetes
service account
is a really good junction
point for Kubernetes identities
and Google Cloud identities.
You can create
them really easily.
It's just a couple
of lines of YAML.
You can associate them
with a workload with one
line in your config file.
And I think, most
importantly, you
can set them up as the default
for an entire Kubernetes
namespace.
That can be really useful if
you have a complicated or large
infrastructure to manage.
Except, your environment
probably didn't look like that.
I am assuming that most
environments look more
like this.
We've got multiple clusters.
They're talking to each other.
They're talking to Google Cloud.
They're talking to
multiple cloud providers.
And we wanted the
solution that we
build to be something that works
for the real world, for you.
So enter the identity namespace.
And this is my perfectly
accurate and entirely
incomprehensible definition.
Jonathan stole my
other definition slide,
so I'm keeping this one.
I know it's usually easier
to go through these things
by explaining what they do
rather than what they are,
but we're going to
use this one anyway.
An identity namespace is a
scope in which a name uniquely
identifies a principle.
And what I mean
by scope is we're
going to be using this
identity namespace to define
a collection of other things.
And within that collection,
anything with the same name
is actually the same thing.
So you can imagine it's
like a magic room where
everybody named Alice is
actually the same person.
It's kind of a strange
concept in the abstract,
but it has some really useful
principles that we'll get into.
And this is what it
looks like in real life.
So when you enable Workload
Identity on your cluster,
your Google Cloud project
gets an identity namespace.
And within that namespace, you
can identify your Kubernetes
service accounts by a
combination of their Kubernetes
namespace and
service account name.
Because the combination of a
name and its identity namespace
is globally unique, and because
the things that we're naming
are Kubernetes
service accounts, this
means we can treat Alice
in cluster A and Alice
in cluster B as the same person.
And for all the crypto
nerds in the room,
there is no Bob or Eve
in this story at all.
All right, so consider
this simplified example.
We've got two
Kubernetes clusters.
Each have two pods.
Each have two namespaces.
Each have two service accounts.
They're completely independent
from an authorization
standpoint.
The identities that
exist in these clusters
are only relevant
inside these clusters.
But if we bind both of these
to the same identity namespace,
then we can start thinking
about logging robot--
from an external
context, we can start
thinking about logging robot
as the same in both Kubernetes
cluster 1 and
Kubernetes cluster 2.
If you toss in a
little Google magic,
we can then associate logging
robot with a Google service
account and use it to
access cloud services.
All right.
So I'm going to
assume, at this point,
the audience is relatively split
down the middle between the
how does that work group and
the show me how to use it group.
So next up, Mike's
going to come up here
and demo how it all works in
practice with a live example,
assuming the demo is working.
And then I'll come
back up and we
can do an architectural
lightning round
for all the architecture nerds.
And that's it.
MICHAEL DANESE: Cool.
I have a mic, yeah.
AARON SMALL: Oh, you have a mic.
MICHAEL DANESE: Oh, wait.
One more slide.
Thank you.
This is my example app.
It's actually a little
bit faded than it was,
but there are a
couple more boxes.
So in GKE US-West, there's a
box around the entire thing,
and that represents my GKE
cluster running in US West.
There's another box around it,
fuzzy llama and GCS server.
So I have this app running
in the fuzzy llama namespace
running as the GCS
server service account.
I used the GCP project name
generator to get fuzzy llama.
And then I have
another GKE cluster
running in an eastern zone.
And it has a namespace fuzzy
llama and my GCS server
app running inside of it.
And this is all running in
my project mikedanese-k8s.
So what these apps do is
they read a object from GCS
and serve it to my
customers, so it's
a pretty sophisticated
app, but we're
going to try to set
it up in this demo.
So you can switch to
the other screen now.
Awesome.
Let's get started.
First thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to deploy a cluster.
How's the size for everybody?
Would you like it a
little bit bigger?
All right, thank you.
So I'm deploying our
cluster to us-west1-b.
If you'll notice, I'm
passing this flag,
identity namespace
equals mikedanese-k8s,
so this is my project-wide
identity namespace.
So I actually
pre-created this cluster
because it's a bit slow.
And the next thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to show you my app.
It's a pretty concise app.
The yellow is the
important part.
So I'm using Google's
Cloud SDK, just the default
client libraries to
construct a token source.
If you are familiar with
how the token source works
in Compute Engine, it
just reads the token
from the metadata server.
I then grab an oauth client
that uses that token source,
and then I read one
object from GCS.
So if we hop over to
my Kubernetes config,
all I really have is a service.
It's a load balance service
that is serving on port 80
to expose my app
to the customer.
I have a service account
named GCS server running
in the fuzzy llama namespace.
And I have an annotation on
that service account that says,
I want to run as the GCS
server GCP IAM service account,
so this service account
has not been created yet.
And then, at the very
bottom, I have my deployment
that runs the app that we just
looked at as my GCS server
Kubernetes service account.
So pretty straightforward, let's
see if we can get it running.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to create that
GCS server service account,
and I'm going to grab
credentials for my cluster.
And apply that
application config,
and then make sure that
that app is coming up.
So give it a couple seconds.
Looks like the GCS
server app is deployed.
And the next thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to give my
Kubernetes service account
permission to run as the GCS
server IAM service account.
So this is a bit dense,
so I'll unpack it.
We are adding an IAM
policy that grants
GCS server in the
fuzzy llama namespace
and the mikedanese-k8s identity
namespace token creator
permission on the
IAM service account
that we want that app to run as.
So this actually
is the step that
grants my Kubernetes
service account permission
to use the IAM service account.
So that looks good.
Next thing I'm
going to do is I'm
going to pull that app
in my west cluster,
and I'm getting 403 forbidden.
Well, that's probably because
we haven't given my application
permission to read that object.
So the next thing
I'm going to do
is going to be to
use gsutil change
acl to grant that GCP service
account permission to read
that image or that object.
And we get kind
of what we expect.
I also noticed-- this
will be important
when we set up the
second half of the demo--
that the cluster name is
exposed as a red header.
So let's go set up the
second half of the demo.
So I'm going to do
the exact same thing.
The cluster is called east, but
it's deployed in us-central.
I actually also
pre-created this cluster.
So the next thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to grab
credentials for it,
and then I'm going to apply
the same application config.
And make sure it's
running, looks pretty good.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to pull east and
west at the same time.
So as you can see,
this one hit west.
That one hit east.
So both my applications are
able to read that GCS object.
The reason we didn't have
to add any acls to set up
the eastern cluster is
because both clusters are
in the same identity namespace,
so Google authenticates them
as the same service account.
So the last thing that
we will do in this demo
is I'm going to revoke acl just
to bring that principle home.
This acl revoke will apply to
both clusters simultaneously.
So west just failed,
and east just failed.
So west and east are
running the same service.
My GCS server application
spans both those clusters,
and that's the demo.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AARON SMALL: OK, I promised
you an architectural lightning
round.
For those of you who kept your
hands up in the beginning,
this bit's for you.
There are five
fundamental new components
that exist as a part
of this new feature.
First, we have an OIDC
provider that runs
on Google's infrastructure.
It provides cluster-specific
metadata and it signs JWTs.
There is a new GKE
metadata server.
It runs as a DaemonSet, meaning
one instance on every node.
It emulates the existing
VMs metadata server,
but it exposes
pod-specific data.
This is going to provide
backwards compatibility
with old client libraries.
And it also offers like
built-in metadata concealment.
I don't know if any of you
are familiar with that feature
that's in beta today on GKE.
It isolates some secrets that
exist in the GCE metadata
server from being exposed
to your workloads,
and this is built into this
new metadata server as well.
We also have a new
annotation that you
saw earlier on the
service account which
lets you indicate which
GCP service account
you want to act as.
That's not actually
a security boundary,
but we do need it
to provide the hint.
And then, of course,
we have Google IAM.
It issues access tokens.
It validates bindings.
The new thing is it also
validates OIDC signatures now.
And then Google Cloud, at
large, it accepts access tokens
and it does pretty
much anything.
We're going to walk
through the flow now.
There's two steps
that are left out,
and that's an authorized
user binding the cluster
to the namespace.
You saw Mike do that earlier.
And the second is the workload
needs to try and do something
to try and access a Google Cloud
Service using a client library.
Once that happens, the
GKE metadata server
is going to request
an OIDC signed JWT
from the control plane.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I should note, that
connection is authenticated
using mutual TLS, and it
uses the node's identity
as the client cert.
Then the GKE metadata
server is going
to use that OIDC signed
JWT to request an access
token for the identity namespace
slash Kubernetes service
account from IAM.
IAM is going to validate that
the appropriate bindings exist,
and then it's going
to validate that it
was signed by the cluster's
correct OIDC provider.
It's then going to
return an access token.
And this access
token, remember, is
for the identity namespace slash
Kubernetes service account.
Then the metadata
server is going
to send that access token
it just got back to IAM,
and IAM is going to exchange
that for a short-lived GCP
service account token
after validating
the appropriate
bindings, of course.
Then the GKE metadata
server returns that token up
to the workload,
and the workload
can obviously use that to
make calls to any GCP service.
There's a lot of token exchanges
and validations going on.
But in practice,
what this means is,
once you've done
the configuration
and set up your
identity namespace,
your identity in Google Cloud
is determined by the Kubernetes
service account that your
workload is running as,
and everything else just works.
[MUSIC PLAYING]